m
[Musique]
abhisit quand on lit on rêve de faire
une oeuvre ensemble à 24 ans on commence
à poser les premières pierres de son
oeuvre à soi on se voudrait seule maison
mais en même temps très malheureux de
l'être il faudrait forcer l'occasion
pour se revoir et on en a pas toujours
le courage si pourtant un seul des amis
d'autrefois disait venez et je serais
vous écoutez le temps qu'il vous faudra
pour vous expliquer alors serez vaincus
une solitude trop précoce
cet ami l'a existe nous avons connu me
colle à la sorbonne elle est étudiante
en lettres et diriger tel journal
lectra aujourd'hui dans l'île saint
louis
elle a ouvert une petite librairie qui
porte le même temps gérer maintenant ce
qu'on appelle pignon surprise c'était
vous avez une librairie mais nous avons
connu comme étudiant comment êtes vous
devenu
et bien parce que celui des chèques à
certains examens vous faisais part
allergies en examen ça allez j je pense
que moi c'était léger au jeu c'est pas
évident quand on a un certain âge et
devient difficile pour certains
tempérament peut-être de passer ce genre
de chose qu'est ce que vous appelez une
certaine neige
24 en ce qui me concerne je donne 90
concerts et vous faisiez une licence de
lettres
oui j'étais étudiante en faculté des
lettres j'avais fondu un journal avec
quelques amis s'appelait l'étrave
vous travaillez oui nous est dit ici et
il ya eu beaucoup aidé journal qui avait
il y avait une partie syndicale en
liaison avec l'unef l'organisation des
étudiants et une partie littéraire
artistique interview publication de
nouvelles ou de poèmes et s'adonnait à
beaucoup d'étudiants la possibilité de
s'exprimer et vous étiez vous-même
rédacteur en chef du comité rédacteur en
chef mais chacun participait à toutes
les tâches vous aviez des lecteurs
assidus
oui on avait un courrier c'est
intéressant
et vous écriviez tout son journal à peu
près tous il y avait certains membres du
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le comité de
lecture connecter de façon bien plus
contenté de critiquer 2
orabi souvent ils n'avaient pas le temps
de faire ou pas me pousse pas le goût
des classiques
à la suite de cela vous avez découvert
cette île boisée oui c'est presque mier
parce qu'en fait on avait dans un
certain ben
presque littéraire vous aviez avant tout
le goût de la littérature oui le goût
des discussions les prises de position
enfin et pour prendre les positions de
meilleure moyenne c'est d'avoir un lieu
et une librairie
oui mon retour de ce soir oui et ainsi
se retrouvent tous les jeunes de c'est
de ce journal qui viennent ici alors
certains ont publié des articles
un roman d'autres qui viennent ici sont
comédiens enfin l'éventail est assez
large il y en a qui font des courts
métrages aussi et on se retrouve on
discute un peu ici puis nous terminons
café vos parents ont testé mes parents à
café juste en face de la librairie donc
les réunions se termine cocasses et or
presque toujours et là les grandes
décisions sont prises entre un verre de
bière une omelette au jambon
alors que des mois un peu comment vous
l'avez 7,7
j'avais tout ce oui mais là encore les
amis m'ont beaucoup de conseillers un
choix de certains étaient plus partir
mans a tiré par la poésie et m'ont dit
il faut avoir ça va les voir y est c'est
comme ça enfin ça c'est
monter petit à petit ce sont mes parents
qui m'ont avancer de l'argent et j'avais
très peu de livres et un ami est venu un
jour en me disant à partir de demain tu
ouvres la porte est ouverte vous élevez
conviennent
une centaine pas plus je suis sûr que
tous les gens qui venaient on avait pu
davantage que moi et alors c'est un
livre que vous aviez vous les aviez
choisi
oui j'avais choisi les auteurs que
j'aimais particulièrement
et est ce qu'il y à issy des livres que
vous m'aimez non non ah mais non je ne
pourrais pas le vendre alors dites moi
quels sont les livres qui sont ici et
que vous aimez michel leiris
les oeuvres de villiers de l'isle-adam
de julien gracq des gens pas forcément
connu ni contemporain mais en général je
les lis des amis les lisent et ça se dit
si tu diffuses assez bien vous avez le
sentiment de participer à cette
librairie pas seulement de venir ici
parce que vous y plaisait mais aussi de
participer au choix d'élire ou 3d y sont
exposés oui enfin moi personnellement
peut-être pas autant que certains autres
enfin je pense ce que par exemple
il ya ici des livres de bertold brecht
via une exposition de bertold brecht ici
des affiches de 4e
c'est un peu peut-être parce que l'ouest
me plaît beaucoup est ce qu'on vous
demande des livres qui lui déplaisent
non tu sais pas je pense que
l'atmosphère la librairie est fait de
telle sorte que les gens qui viennent
ici demande toujours des choses
intéressantes que je n'ai pas toujours
parce que j'ai pas un fonds
considérables que je commande très
rapidement pour satisfaire le client
jusqu'à 10h jusqu'à 10 heures du soir
oui c'est libre et nokia
oui mais les gens flânent et c'est un
lieu propice il ya de la musique et on
peut s'y retrouver entre et se sentir un
peu à l'aise chez soir mais je vous
demande de me parler du talent est un
peu en amie nicole est une fille qui qui
comprend énormément les choses c'est
extrêmement
on dira ouvertes c'est-à-dire qu'à
l'accueil à l'accueil beaucoup les les
confidences un peu
selon ce qu'elle tient très bien son
rôle dans cette librairie où elle en
permanence
qu'est ce que vous faites pour défendre
elles y vont par exemple il vous est
arrivé défendre barbey d aurevilly oui
alors là c'est en train d'une discussion
et ça peut aller assez loin qui a duré
assez longtemps et en général j'ai
toujours des airs de julien gracq qui
m'appartiennent et que je prête aux gens
comme ça ça ne les engage à rien elie si
ça leur plaît ils viennent en acheter
d'autres vais vraiment livres avaient
péri en ce qui concerne julien gracq oui
parce qu'il est assez peu connue grâce à
un écrivain que nous avons tous beaucoup
ce n'est pas intéressant
enfin l'un d'entre nous nous à nous la
fait découvrir et depuis nous l'aimons
beaucoup et ceux qui écrivent parmi nos
eaux sont très influencés par gracq et
vous l'aimez propres parce qu'il
n'échappe à une sorte de
le demande de du préjugé littéraire qui
a envahi une certaine littérature
actuelle qui est un peu l'écart et vous
voulez et nous avons l'intention de
reprendre ce journal le transformer en
revue seulement à caractère littéraire
et ses amis vous apporte des manuscrits
j'aime toujours là un tas de manuscrits
et que je fais lire d'autres gens nous
en discutons et
c'est une sorte de critique qu'on se
fait de la à l'autre des uns aux autres
et vous même vous écris des croix des
poèmes
moi j'ai pris des sortes de de ce plutôt
que vous faites lire par vos amis tout
ça et vous lisez vous même je lis qu'ils
écrivent également
je pense surtout à jean paul sartre
mise à part la nausée et camus il vous
paraît des mots dits oui malraux aussi
parce que l'époque a changé et nous
l'avons lu enfin je crois que pour
parler littérature engagée
c'est en somme faire un programme c'est
en somme avoir l'illusion de de mordre
sur une pénalité qui me il me semble
nous échappe
avec l'été politique par exemple
certains écrivains
se sont imaginés hâtivement qu'ils avec
un livre pouvait faire une révolution
je crois que ce faux qu'est-ce que vous
rêvez de faire enfin donc cette revue
est plus loin parce que vous imaginez
plus loin en ce qui concerne ces lieux
j'ai une cave en dessous que je voudrais
aménagé et faire des expositions et
mettre des sièges en fait chaud très
confortable ce qui permettrait aux gens
de se retrouver quand ils désireraient
est toujours tout est lié les amis la
revue la librairie le quartier les
voiles ans des amis qui grâce à nicole
ont tous des raisons d'aimer cette
librairie comme si elles leur
appartenait
il voit ses gravures qui sont là sont de
vous et comment avez vous été amené à
les exposer ici j'ai eu l'occasion de
faire une exposition à la cité
universitaire au pavillon belge et
inamical est venu voir cette exposition
elle m'a donné envie de montrer quelques
gravures à nicole qui a trouvé ces
choses très bien comme ça vous car vous
êtes vert et vous habitez la cité
universitaire citu et je suppose que ça
pose un certain nombre de problèmes 2001
maier oui tu as tellement ça pose
énormément de problèmes le fait est que
nous avons une chambre qui est une chose
tout même très très importante mais nous
n'avons pas d'atelier alors le problème
est qu'il faut travailler dans sa
chambre
les conditions ne sont eux mêmes
difficiles vous êtes comédiens vous
lisiez oui jolie fable naïve demi heure
ne serait ce que pour les textes que
j'ai à prendre
oui et les livres qui sont plus
ils suffisamment chaque année les 600
d'ici m'ont permis d'être coupé cage de
découvrir certaines comme théâtre permis
d
de changer aussi une direction d'un
siège est à naples 3 gars chez vous les
entendez beaucoup parler discuter de
littérature oui est ce que ça vous fait
ça vous ennuie bien ça m'intéresse
jusqu'à certains mois et ça m'ennuyait
sakho franchement vous même
oui
vous avez reçu beaucoup à 7
sur la ligne et pas nous je sais pas ma
participation aux rencontres à trouver
ma façon m'intéresse c'est encore pas je
joue quelque chose enfin je veux pas
trop bien méchant
je fais pas mal de choses c'était bien
joué nous une pièce très intéressante
avec avec jean marie serreau en festival
et bourgogne une pièce à quatre scènes
avec des actions différentes dans des
lieux différents qui se passe en même
temps avec le public au milieu du
réceptif à tout et laisse tomber un coup
tous les sens et je crois que vous avez
des chansons oui oui et vous accompagnez
la victoire oui et ses chansons voulait
chanter je les chante plus chanteau
copains mais
j'ai déjà chanté nantes ans dans un
petit cabaret de lille
j'ai pas j'ai pas beaucoup le temps de
chanter façon mais de toutes ces
activités que vous avez quelle est
l'activité eux il leur faut une
essentielle je crois que pour l'instant
je suis comédien ou plutôt vous êtes
surtout quand même et vous rêvez de
rester comédienne non je voudrais tout
faire mais c'est pas possible
et comment êtes-vous mais je suis venu
une collaboration est le numéro 2 les
trams et puis je sentais les fragments
journal qui est monté à la salle je
trouve exactement l'ambiance travail et
je suis lié d'amitié avec l'équipe et
j'y reste
et comme à bord des cercueils scellés
j'avais demandé la collaboration avec
l'état sur un numéro spécial qui était
consacrée à l'algérie
j'avais fait pas quelques mois car vous
êtes ingénieur vous appartenez impayés
en mouvement et pays qui viennent subir
une guerre difficile et douloureuse dont
vous êtes vous même ce leader et à payer
informations également est-ce que vous
vous sentez se libère de ses
préoccupations littéraires qui sont un
peu abstraite balaie tout évidemment
mais toute littérature n'est pas
uniquement de peu recherches formelles
complètement abstraite parce que en fin
de compte la matière première de toute
littérature toute oeuvre d'art au départ
c'est l'homme n'essaie pas sa propre
construction que que s'attelle toute
bonne littérature littérature vrai aussi
et je pense que pour la jeunesse
française aussi la guerre d'algérie est
quelque chose d'important comme l'a été
pour nos effets qu'en fin de compte ce
que nous cherchons nous cherchons
quelque chose qui soit en commun et nous
cherchons tous ensemble vous allez
retourner en alu
vous allez continuer à créer mais est-ce
que vous prendrez d'autres
responsabilités
enfin nécessairement je pense que dans
notre pays qui vient de subir comme un
vulgaire assez désastreuse pour lui se
contenter uniquement d'écrire je crois
que c'est assez insuffisant et tout ce
qui peut être utilisable ou ou d'une
quelconque utilité pour la constitution
du pays doit être le tour tu utilisais
je continuais certainement écrire
nécessairement même mais je compte aussi
m'intéresser à l'enseignement par
exemple oui content que nomade et vous
allez continuer à écrire il le problème
de la langue
évidemment on peut se poser parce que je
peux aussi en arabe mais je crois que je
continuer pendant un certain temps à
écrire en français pour moi une langue
c'est je ne sois absolument aucun
problème d'incompatibilité ni de de
déchirements entre deux langues entre
deux cultures absolument pas c'est en
même temps il faut beaucoup plus parlé
de d'une culture à double enracinement
plutôt que que de déchiré entre deux
cultures qui n'existent pas parce que
individuellement on arrive toujours
tendance à faire une synthèse parfois au
milieu d'une discussion qui pose les
problèmes les plus graves
on traverse la rue pour aller se
détendre au café soulève discret des
parents nicole on joue un peu et puis on
parle de cette fameuse revue elle se
ride est illustré si possible sur le
plan financier on n'est guère à jour
n'est pas le plus grave
ce premier numéro aura pour thème le
bonheur c'est un thème un peu vague mais
on compte beaucoup sur le talent de
chacun
pour l'illustrer valablement à propos
des manuscrits à piana la librairie et
en plus soit est venu faire des petits
pots
je pense plus
vous étiez de quoi notamment la paroisse
personnellement je vous dirais très
franchement surplombe les cris quand je
n'aime pas ce mélange à la fois de
poésie mystique de recherche depuis six
mois sans heurts et je pense même pas
que ce qu'il est sa place dans l'humeur
ou tout du moins ce qu'avance se passer
l'accord même dans la franche moi je
marquerai de l'amour mais
effectivement il n'a pas sa place de
numéro un rapport qu'il ait sa place
dans le numéro c'est rennes a été fêtée
cette prime tout soupire est devenue
comme une marée vous êtes une portée
jusqu'aux villes voisines qui nous
livrer sans hésiter leurs prises hors
inépuisable et tout le texte lui-même
pourtant le savoir parce qu'elle mon
bonheur que ce qui concerne directement
je suis d'accord c'est déjà ça avait
duré de complaisance à la fatalité
mais dites-moi ce texte de pierre qui
vaut tant de commentaires des uns et des
autres dites moi est ce que c'est et
comment le situer disons pour moi le ce
que fait pierre se rapproche beaucoup de
ce que fait profiter certains ne serait
peut-être pas d'accord mais je pense que
pour moi il se rapproche de ses heures
un peu lumineuse le par exemple matinale
les brumes qu'ils découvrent ou la
sensation d'un souvenir qu'on recherche
vers l'enfer lequel on est tendu
pour moi c'est vrai c'est très très
proche de deux trousses et c'est
pourquoi j'ai le plus grand plaisir que
j'ai vraiment c'est de lire proust c'est
pourquoi quand je lis un texte de pierre
je me sens vraiment attirer et à la fois
repoussée parce que ce que prouve tout à
fait il l'a bien fait et je sais très
bien que si maintenant on veut écrire
quelque chose ce n'est plus long de
cette voie là qu'il faut aller c'est un
pilier et on salue au passage et et on
passe du toit on vient de discuter
beaucoup votre texte enfin le texte que
vous avez donnée pour ce numéro qui se
prépare sur le bonheur il semble que
votre personnalité gêne un peu tout le
monde en même temps que elle fascine
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que par exemple
ce texte n'est pas pris dans un ensemble
social ce n'est pas un texte qui répond
à des préoccupations sociales concernant
le bonheur c'est un texte qui cherche à
être une qui cherche à être une démarche
à partir des quelques données que chacun
peut trouver en lui-même et c'est
peut-être ce qui gêne beaucoup les gens
puisque le bonheur et peut-être
envisager actuellement surtout dans son
ensemble global social et la
personnalité de pierre ici semble avoir
un rayonnement
oui d'abord parce que sur le plan du
langage de son expression personnelle je
pense que sont engagés sans expression
personnelle sont très élaborés beaucoup
plus élaborée qui ne le sont ils aussi à
la fois beaucoup plus réticents et
beaucoup plus expansif que nous le
sommes
je vois ces textes par exemple qui qui
sont là toujours à notre disposition
discussions de ce qu'il fait de ce qu'il
ne fait pas de ce qu'il réussit à faire
c'est un aspect qui à la fois me
m'intéresse beaucoup me choque un peu et
entraîne entraîne parfois dans le sang
ce qui est mauvais enfin j'ai fait des
textes parfois en pensant à lui et je
sais que ce n'est pas du tout ma veine
ou plutôt ce qui ce qui normalement on
peut m'attirer
comment supporter bien écrite et que
vous faites les uns aux autres oui en
fait je n'ai pas tellement eu l'occasion
de recevoir de critiques parce que je ne
montre pas tellement les textes que je
fais je lisais ces désordres
plutôt oui je suis réticent quand enfin
je suis pas encore assez assuré de moi
même je ne pense pas avoir suffisamment
mûri emma et mon écriture est aussi un
centre de conception pour pouvoir comme
ça l'est en discute et enfin je me
sentirais pas mon aise
on juge aussi les plus grands parmi les
maîtres à penser avant d'être choqués
n'oubliez pas que pour s'affirmer
il faut quelquefois brûler ce que
d'autres s'en tenir
et si on faisait un peu le plus en
citant tech on peut faire un bilan des
expériences littéraires dont vous vous
sentez proche qui cytheriae vous prenons
les dernières cinquante ans par exemple
commençons par proust vous voulez bien
oui je me sentirai assez proche de
proust en raison de cette minutie qu'il
met à écrire c'est à son expérience qui
qui n'est pas à proprement parler
individuel mais qui très vite devient
une expérience vrai pour tous dans la
mesure où ce qu'il dit les faits ce sont
les véritables faits qu'ils rapportent
sont très vite vrai pour tous donc c'est
de lui que vous sentez le plus proche
dans les dernières cinquante enfants
début du siècle et aux logiques qui a
beaucoup marqué la jeunesse ce qui me
gêne beaucoup chez gide c'est c'est
d'ailleurs deux choses c'est par exemple
rapports très étroits qu'il a avec dieu
et ce pathétique ce pathétique mouvement
qui le rapproche ou qu'il éloigne de
dieu et c'est d'ailleurs la même chose
d'une certaine manière aussi
l'importance considérable cas pour lui
toute la littérature toute la culture
antérieur cette sorte d'encyclopédie de
la culture qui lui semble être peut-être
le sommet de la littérature et je vois
un rapport étroit entre cet attachement
à dieu et cet attachement à la culture
de son temps et des époques antérieures
craignons les surréalistes qui ont eu
beaucoup d'influencé ou alors au
contraire là et c'est ça qui est très
nette dans la même mesure où les
surréalistes ni dieu dans cette même
mesure ini une cercle iny la culture
tout recommence avec que par cette
double négation et sartre qui a marqué
beaucoup la jeunesse de la guerre et de
l'après-guerre bien là je pense qui
repart exactement au même point que les
surréalistes c'est à dire à partir cette
négation de dieu est cependant il ya un
effort de construction beaucoup plus
grand parce que les surréalistes il est
évident que la négation presque à
l'infini qu'il menait n'est pas n'est
pas suffisante face il ya quelque chose
qui manque très très nettement et sartre
c'est une littérature engagée
non je dis oui mais enfin le sartre
d'après guerre
je pense par exemple aux sardes de la
nausée ou les données d'expérience sont
semblables à celles des surréalistes on
part des mêmes données
face au monde 7 n'osait ressenti est
très identique a ouverte il ressentit
ans sous l'effet de la drogue et à
l'écriture automatique de même d'accord
mais moi je voudrais vous parler aux
sartre auquel les gens pensent enfin le
grand public pense mais alors qu'en
pensez vous lequel c'est à dire le
sartre engagé existentialiste c'est à
dire que les points de vue théorique de
sacchi qui réaffirme encore tout
récemment par exemple dans la raison
dialectique sont absolument passionnant
il ya un état du monde qui fait
certainement son engagement cet état du
monde uni n'est pas niable et
l'engagement lui-même né pagnol mais au
fond à partir de ce moment là s'il ne
s'agit plus du tout littérature il
s'agit d'une action dans le monde qui
est très importante qui est mais qui
n'est plus du tout de la littérature
mais ce que vous n'aimez pas c'est la
littérature qui en résulte
oui parce que c'est au fond il me semble
une assez grosse erreur que de penser
que la littérature engagée puisse avoir
une action
ce moment là il vaut mieux très
nettement écrire des ouvrages théoriques
abstrait où tous les états du monde ont
tendance à rendre compte assez
abstraitement mais parce qu'aussi on
s'adresse à des professeurs qui sont
peut-être ceux qui sont plus aptes à
vous comprendre quant au roman engagé je
ne vois pas très bien l'intérêt kenzy un
peu comme pour gide pour camus ya un
rapport avec le divin ou avec un bonheur
un bonheur un peu vague
ce bonheur solaire dans cette région de
la méditerranée qui fait que cas mieux
peut-être plus un homme de théâtre
quelqu'un écrive et dans la littérature
actuelle proche à l'heure de vaud par
exemple c'est au fond je vois deux
choses par exemple je me sens assez
proche de julien gracq d'une certaine
façon et d'une autre façon du nouveau
roman les deux d'ailleurs julien gracq
un nouveau roman s'ignorant assez
complètement
pourtant je le revois des points communs
essentiels par une même préoccupation de
la géographie dans son sens très large
de l'espace et vous vivez et cependant
dans une époque qui est particulièrement
difficile
est ce que vous pensez personnellement
en rendre compte qu'il est nécessaire
d'en rendre compte
un oui très certainement comme je disais
tout à l'heure je pense qu'on peut en
rendre compte par exemple en écrivant
des ouvrages théoriques je veux dire
comme ça dans la raison dialectique ou
comme lévi strauss dans l'anthropologie
structurale c'est passionnant mais par
ailleurs je pense qu'on peut mener
d'autres ouvrages qui n'aurait rien à
voir avec une théorie qui s'en mêlerait
qui s'y perdrait un peu les habitudes
les trams n'ont pas toujours un langage
aussi abstrait et si nicole après une
journée très littéraire rêve d'écouté
des romances son ami le comédien lui
chante sa dernière chanson en
s'accompagnant à l'habitat il s'appelle
claude man
n'oubliez pas son nom il est maintenant
le partenaire de jeanne moreau dans le
film de jacques demy la baie des anges
qui lui donnera sa première chance il
illustrait son visage fait le show
chante une chanson de moi là
c'est ma dernière chance aussi
l'histoire d'une fille qui se balade
dans la rue et qui raconte sa vie à tout
le monde sauf son histoire qui parle
tout seul un soldat qu'il soit dû au
grand nombre ou dieu sait quoi toujours
ses obligations très vite perdu mes
illusions mais quand je danse dans ses
bras oubliez tout je croyais pas que
demain ne marcherait pas je ne sais plus
si c'était une valve soit menu mais sa
tournée mais ça tournait quand ils me
parlaient tout bas j'aurais mais
j'entendais pas qu'on s'y glissaient si
le disait
c'est une base un menuet je vais plus à
voir mais j'ai dansé simple partant avec
suzy mais je dis ça pour me faire mal je
sais qu'il ne disait jamais que des
douceurs démons banal de ce que l'on ne
rit jamais
je ne sais plus si c'était tu ne vas sur
un menu et mais ça tournait mais sa
tournée quand ils me parlaient tous
bords je révèle j'entendais pas là
[Musique]
ça n'a pas tourné la tête de savoir
qu'ils ne reviendraient pas peut-être
et si j'en parle comme ça tout le temps
c'est pour passer le temps
peut-être bien qu'il est vivant ou
peut-être bien qu'il est mort mais en
nous comme s'il est vivant
alors oui mais crient pas souvent
voilà
là
allah
en vain
[Musique]